so this footage to you feels authentic i
would say
yes
let me read this again not involved it's
important for me to say on the record
that this is not something i am aware i
am involved in
like this is such a weird phrasing but i
know i'm not going to be able to
convince anyone no matter what i say
what if he sold his likeness rights to
the level that they can deep fake him
legally
oh
what if that's a great question
the biggest tech company in the world
what if they own him digitally that is a
great question first actually you know
like that i don't know that's some
phrasing y'all
that is that's my headline
[Music]
what's going on there reject nation koi
giandro yeah
there it is
easily the biggest spider-man fan i know
and he is not like me when it comes to
the leaks and stuff for spider-man no
way home in fact he tends to avoid all
of it here's what's going on right now
okay i'm sure you guys have already
heard late to doing a video about this
this footage going around of andrew
garfield on set of spider-man no way
home you've probably seen it already if
you're clicking on this video here's
where i'm a little bit confused by the
situation some people and this doesn't
always mean it a lot of times even
myself i'm guilty of this of going it
must mean it's real when this happens
sometimes when uh people get like
blocked or copyright striked like
removed from twitter or youtube a lot of
times that means it's legit other times
that means it's real and then there's
people who have been doing videos about
this and i saw on youtube that some
people uploaded this video directly got
a bunch of views was not taken down off
youtube and i'm like out of anywhere
should be taking off youtube a friend of
ours chris 3c films he did a breakdown
of this he featured the footage himself
and his video is still public and has
like 100 000 views
so
does that really mean that it's real or
not now i don't know if you know this
koi andrew garfield said this once i
came out i mean he said this in variety
it's important for me to say on the
record that this is not something i'm
aware i'm involved in i'm not the
werewolf
i know i'm not i'm not going to be able
to convince anyone no matter what i say
i'm effed basically is what he's saying
look i'm going to say this really quick
i saw the images and i could see where
some people are really trying to break
this down like is this real is this fake
it looks like he's breathing in his in
his in his suit but i can't tell if it's
cropping i ended up seeing hd version i
believe he's in this movie but i don't
know if this is real or not but what are
your thoughts so i wanted to be here to
represent the other side of fandom but i
love how much coverage you guys are
doing on this i love the push for no way
home but i want to be the guy that says
there is no reality where we can make
this movie as good as the hype is
demanding at this point what i'm worried
about is if this movie at two and a half
hours can possibly be all of the things
that we're prescribing it to be imagine
a movie where toby and andrew don't show
up now it's this part that's the concern
how much money are they now going like
we've got to give andrew garfield 80
million dollars like they have all the
power if they're not actually in this
they literally have control the likes of
which we haven't seen in hollywood in 40
years yeah but we need as spider-man
fans to acknowledge that yes toby
maguire was this great steve ditko
spider-man yes andrew garfield was some
of the right and some of the wrong
things about brian michael bennett's
ultimate spider-man and yes tom holland
represents this incredible version of
the avengers spider-man that is part of
a team dynamic that doesn't really
function on his own the way we want it
to and together
i don't even know if that tone works
okay look at those like those three
spider-men you don't know if totally
those three spider-man world with the
way we've introduced tom holland
spider-man will we be able to live in a
world where those those all those
different tones land end game is a
masterpiece of tone balance sure i don't
know unless it's one scene in this movie
and then they let us have a spider-verse
fourth film which is my theory my theory
is they've secretly shot a fourth movie
all right my theory is we've got a third
film end with a post credit scene
there's a fourth spider-man movie that's
going to come out way sooner than we
expect at sony that's the only way i see
this working because you have to give
them enough time that it doesn't feel
like a letdown if we just see toby like
hey or like pizza time
and that's it we need more than pizza
time and frankly how is this movie going
to be anything but my point of this this
footage is even if it is real it could
have been him visiting set and someone
got deep faked him in a suit it could
easily be that's one of the theories
i just don't know if it's possible to
live up to the expectation we've set so
i want to be the guy going hey december
we got a spider-man movie that's good
enough for me do you believe they're in
it or not i believe they're in it okay
so you do believe they're in it but i
think we need to expect less the footage
looks like it's from some guy's phone on
set yeah and i'm like who's the pa
that'll never work who would allow that
to be that's what the footage looks like
but then there's like an hd version
where i'm like okay that looks really
crisp and clean and maybe they're
setting up a camera shot or something
yeah who would leak this because you
know how that trailer did leave the
early cut that makes me go damn you know
there's some snitches on here yeah
they're about to get stitches there's a
lot there's thousands of people that
work on this movie so i'm sure someone's
bound to be like let me just hook up a
friend what i expect is if the footage
is cell phone footage it's someone
trying to get some clout and send it to
a friend and that friend leaked it i'd
imagine it's someone like i like this
girl i'm gonna send her some pictures of
amanda i'm gonna send some pictures of
spider-man and then like someone's like
well they broke up with me like i think
it's probably uh a chain that leaked out
because i if you're on set you the last
thing you want is to never work again
and this person's never going to work
again especially for something of this
nate i mean i imagine that if you have
some if you have the knowledge of that
level of secrecy yeah there's a part of
you too that's also like
i gotta tell someone yeah
i just don't know one if it'll work
tonally in one film what i would do is
the interdimensional sinister six where
they're gathered from other universes or
tom holland is in their universe and
then he needs to recruit them and then
the end is then being recruited then you
get an entire other movie where you can
actually play with those tones andrew
garfield spider-man doesn't make sense
next to toby's much less toms i mean i i
feel like with the mcu they know how to
like bring characters from different
tones they do but it takes a whole movie
it does it takes two and a half hours i
don't think we have a two and a half
hour andrew so are you worried about
them being in this
i'm worried that you believe they're in
it i believe they're in it but i'm
worried about them being in it okay i'm
the one guy that's like i hope they're
in it reluctantly like i'm i'm both
excited and concerned that it won't be
what we need it to be i don't want a
glorified cameo like especially after
all this hype movie makes a billion
dollars and we're all like wait 30
seconds like it's it's a really tricky
spot everyone's in and i'm not sure a
movie has ever had this much hype about
something that everyone's denying that
doesn't mean it's not true like andrew
garfield saying i'm not in it doesn't
mean he's not in it it's his job to say
i'm not in well it's like the way he
says it let me read this again not in
vault like it's important for me to say
on the record that this is not something
i am aware i am involved in
like this is such a weird phrasing but i
know i'm not going to be able to
convince anyone no matter what i say
what if he sold his likeness rights to
the level that they can deep fake him
legally
oh
what if that's a great question sony the
biggest tech company in the world what
if they own him digitally that is a
great question first actually you know
like that i don't know that's some
phrasing y'all
that is that's my headline of this video
what if he is some specific that is very
oh wow that you know that's not
far-fetched especially when knowing sony
home and things and it's disney knowing
what they do like
luke
yeah i mean this could literally be who
framed roger rabbit's andrew garfield
like i think fellow even came out with
saying like yeah mark hamill really
wasn't involved with that and the amount
of time you're in the suit what if
they're not on set that is such a good
point i changed my entire purpose
my original purpose was to say i don't
want to know now i'm like yo deep fake
garfield what if they got that boy a
footage inserted it re-upped it got some
voice over because you got like you hear
those voice-over things those defect
voiceovers you can absolutely construct
a garfield oh absolutely sometimes it
looks so real i can't even tell what if
spider-man is here but it's not i don't
believe that but i think
that's a great
back-up scenario saga it's just a ton of
tom holland they couldn't
i mean with the guy uh i think shamook
the one who would do like the star wars
defect was hired by lucasfilm after
seeing his youtube videos i mean it's a
really it's a growing market it's a
great market it's creepy it's scary and
that quote sounds way more like andrew
garfield found out he was in the movie
like he got informed it's like by this
point i'm like dude other people are
admitting it just admit it yeah wait
like and what has toby said is toby been
on the record uh no okay he's out there
throwing phones the [ __ ] out of the way
i can't see there are cars there
[ __ ] all the quotes line up with
the both being in it and not in it it's
just a matter of whether or not we as
fans can enjoy what they give us that's
what i'm concerned about if they're in
it please don't put it in the trailer if
they're not in it i hope no one revolts
but if they're in the trailer i think
you're going to get excited
yeah
but i'm mad at myself for it like i'm
already like yes i'll get excited do am
i happy about that no but it's weird
i'll be right here next time we're going
to react and i'm going to go and like
like immediately yeah yeah i'll have
buyer's remorse the second i see them in
a trailer so this footage to you feels
authentic i would say
yes
i don't know i fall for the dumbest
stuff sometimes and i've avoided it
completely i've literally i've not seen
a thing and now of course i'm on this
video so
the thing is we don't know if it's real
though and that's amazing people have
been saying like did people getting
copyright striked and blocked but i'm
like but i see a couple of huge youtube
videos that feature it it's still there
can we also acknowledge while we're
talking about the matrix and spider-man
both christmas releases that we live in
a time where there is video footage of
an actor and we don't know if it's weird
yeah if there's ever been a time the
matrix is relevant it is 1999 right
before the internet boom and right now
right before the deep fake boom my big
thing is i think this this last five
years this this this five years in the
past and in the future i think this is
the last time we have any deniability of
reality because we're about to enter a
new reality i think we're going to
consider this prehistoric times every
moment is catalogued if you look at pre
uh uh video cameras when things were
just written down that was uh
interpretive that was objective right
we're about to enter a new era where
even this we can cut right now that's
going to end the video that's going to
change things we're about to enter a
time this is going to be considered
prehistoric because every moment isn't
documented and right now we're seeing
the birth of that with this video we
literally don't know if that's weird
because of right now this is the end of
days of our days our kids will never
understand our confusion like well
nothing is it's all of it it's all
subjective and objective
it's what i'm saying
all right
that's that's the note to end on god
guys reality's about to shift plug in if
you haven't done so you got to subscribe
to koi jondro's channel
there is no garfield is he in the movie
yes and though
a little bit
hit that like button what do you guys
think do you guys believe that footage
is real
and hey we'll catch you guys soon
existential crisis
[Music]